The sun was setting on the Norwegian port
of Bergen.
It was early July, 1349, and off in the distance,
a lone ship was crossing the line of the horizon.
The ship bobbed calmly, port to starboard,
coming closer into view.
The inhabitants of Bergen noticed its tattered
sails and lack of movement on board.
As gently as it had appeared, the ship entered
the harbour and run aground.
Every sailor on board was dead.
The people of Bergen were fully aware of the
events unfolding across the rest of Europe
over the previous two years: a mysterious,
malevolent, life-consuming force had spread
death and decay all over the continent.
Until that day, Bergen had been spared.
Norse mythology used to tell stories of Naglfar,
a ship made entirely of the nails and toenails
of the dead.
Naglfar would appear at the onset of Ragnarok,
the twilight of the Gods and the end of times.
The ship of the dead would ferry the forces
of chaos to bring destruction upon the realms
of the Gods, and of humankind.
Like Naglfar, the ghost ship of Bergen had
appeared from nowhere, carrying on board an
agent of dissolution and chaos, the scourge
of humanity.
The Black Death.
Revelation 6:8
“And I looked, and there was a pale green
horse.
Its rider was named Death, and Hades was following
after him.
They were given authority over a fourth of
the earth, to kill by the sword, by famine,
by plague, and by the wild animals of the
earth.”
[Note: I suggest the quote above is simply
shown on screen, not read aloud]
How can we define the Black Death today?
We could say it was the most successful human
conqueror in the history of mankind, if success
is measured by how many trees are cut down
to feed the funeral pyres.
We could say it was the greatest strategist,
if greatness is measured by how little soil
remains to bury the dead.
What we eventually defined as ‘the Black
Death’ was a mid-14th century pandemic of
bubonic plague that came knocking at the gates
of Asia, Europe, and Africa, rapping with
the soft paws of a sickly rat, a guest uninvited
with cruel intent.
But if you look at the way the Black Death
spread, attacked, and preyed on humans; if
you consider the effectiveness with which
it encircled and annihilated entire Nations
… well, you’d be forgiven for thinking
that an even more sinister, unnatural power
was at play, hell-bent on bringing about the
end of times.
But this wasn’t the first time that humanity
had withstood an invasion by this malevolent
angel: it had spread its wings back in the
6th Century, known then as the Justinian Plague.
But too much time had passed; too many memories
had been lost.
When the pandemic returned, humankind was
completely unprepared.
The Black Death had laid dormant for eight
centuries, trapped in a purgatory of meagre
rodent prey.
Almost like a lifeless object, it awaited
its time of reprisal against its human enemy.
We could not tell why it hated us, but we
did find out how much it could hate us.
Black Death: Origins
It is still unclear where the Black Death
first came from.
Possibly China, or maybe in the steppe region,
where a plague reservoir stretches from the
north-western shores of the Caspian Sea into
southern Russia.
A plague reservoir looks like a vast area
of wilderness, almost entirely devoid of human
life.
It may have been there, amongst a population
of marmots, rats, and other rodents, that
it first appeared, invisible to the naked
eye.
The unaware mammals all carried the minions
of Black Death, a bacterium which later generations
would classify as Yersinia Pestis.
This is the pathogen at the root of both the
bubonic and pneumonic plagues, and it was
believed to have been endemic to Central Asia.
We don’t know the exact time in which the
disease started to spread from rodents to
humans, but we know of an early outbreak in
1331, which erupted in China during the rule
of the Yuan dynasty.
This dynasty had been founded by Kublai Khan,
the grandson of Genghis Khan.
The Mongols had been an irresistible force
for more than a century, but they had finally
met their match.
Three years later, the Black Death had killed
more than 90 percent of the population of
Hebei province, near the Capital of Dadu,
or modern-day Beijing.
The death toll surpassed 5 million people.
These were the effects of the conquering disease
in just one province.
As of 1200, China had a total population of
more than 120 million, but a census in 1393
found only 65 million Chinese accounted for.
Almost half of the population of a great Empire
lay dead.
As the Yuan Dynasty was replaced by the Mings,
many hundreds of thousand, even millions,
died in battle or starved.
But many, many more millions had fallen prey
to the Black Death.
After the first outbreaks, the rats and their
fleas, ridden with Yersinia Pestis, started
their journey westward, as stowaways to the
caravans travelling along the Silk Road.
At the end of a long day’s travel, the merchants
would stop at the numerous caravansaries – or
resting places - dotting the Silk Road.
These made perfect occasions for the possessed
fleas to infect rats, animals, and other travellers.
Caravans upon caravans, criss-crossing the
plains of central Asia, unwittingly obeyed
the bidding of the Black Death, spreading
the plague across all of Asia and the Middle
East.
By 1335 the Black Death had infected Persia.
During that year, the local Mongol ruler Abu
Said died of bubonic plague.
An estimated one third of all Persians died
in the ensuing epidemic, an event that marked
the beginning of the end of Mongol rule in
the region.
More Central Asian cities and communities
fell one by one under the shadow of the Angel
of death: Talas, Samarkand, even Sarai- this
was the capital of another Mongol state, the
Khanate of the Golden Horde.
It is as though the Black Death had a personal
grudge against the Mongols.
Maybe it simply exploited their legendary
mobility to reach the four corners of the
World, exacting a toll after each passage.
The plague did not discriminate amongst its
victims.
Any King, Queen, or Khan could become easy
prey.
Out of the Land of Darkness
After every sweep of the plague, each population
center would have lost at least 40 percent
of its citizens.
Sometimes, the death tolls climbed as high
as 70 percent.
Understandably, the inhabitants of stricken
cities fled in panic, but this only contributed
to further outbreaks of the disease.
Soon, the Black Death had reached the Middle
East,, where some scholars had already taken
notice of the catastrophe that had nearly
obliterated Asia.
Ibn al-Wardi, a Syrian writer, and later a
victim of the plague, recorded that the Black
Death “came out of The Land of Darkness.”
which may implicate Central Asia – or possibly
a much darker and more remote land beyond
this Earth.
The Egyptian scholar Al-Mazriqi noted all
of Asia was depopulated, as far as the Korean
Peninsula.
His own country was no luckier: Cairo, by
then the most populous city in Africa, lost
52% of its inhabitants.
Almost 14,000 died in just two days.
The corpses were so many that in a rare occurrence,
religious authorities waived the required
prayers for the dead: there were simply too
many.
Ibn Battuta, the great traveler and chronicler
of the 14th Century, had noted in his Travel
memoir that as of 1345, "the number that died
daily in Damascus had been two thousand"
Battuta also wrote that the survivors had
been able to defeat the plague through prayer.
But Muslim religious practices may have played
in the Black Death’s favor.
The Hajj, the annual pilgrimage to Mecca,
provided a great route for Yersinia Pestis
to seek new hosts.
By 1349, the holy city of Mecca had been struck
by the plague.
The Moroccan historian Khaldun left behind
an account of the Apocalyptic wasteland:
"Civilization both in the East and the West
was visited by a destructive plague which
devastated nations and caused populations
to vanish … Cities and buildings were laid
waste, roads and way signs were obliterated,
settlements and mansions became empty, dynasties
and tribes grew weak.
The entire inhabited world changed."
Until recently, we (the descendants of the
survivors), assumed that the Sahara Desert
had stopped the outbreak, that the Black Death
had spared sub-Saharan Africa.
Medieval written records for that region never
mention the plague, and the area lacks the
most macabre memento of the pandemic: the
‘plague pits’ or mass graves.
It is not entirely clear how, but the thralls
of Black Death, the Yersinia, thanks to the
fleas and the rodents … somehow crossed
the inhospitable expanse of sand and infected
communities on both coasts of the continent.
Archaeologists have found evidence of societal
collapse and abandonment of towns in sites
such as Akrokrowa, in Ghana or Ife, Nigeria.
Other cities and settlements in East Africa
were also abandoned during the mid-14th Century,
from the coast of the Red Sea, down to Tanzania
and even Madagascar.
Proof is scarce, as geneticists were not able
to secure DNA from African victims of that
period … and yet the patterns of sudden
collapse and de-population are too suspicious.
The Black Death was definitely bent on total
World domination.
Asia had fallen.
The conquest of the Middle East and Africa
raged on.
The next target was Europe.
Waves of Yersinia Pestis could have infected
the Russian principalities at a very early
stage of the campaign for Asia.
But the plans of the Black Death had been
momentarily thwarted by its early foes, and
victims: the Mongols.
The Mongol state in Central Asia, the Khanate
of the Golden Horde, had converted to Islam,
and the trade with Christians was no longer
tolerated.
As a result, the caravan routes from Asia
to Europe had been cut off, meaning that contagion
of the plague stopped abruptly on the Mongol
border with the Russian principalities.
But as I said, the Black Death was a cunning
strategist and would find its way to Europe,
one way or another.
Twenty-three Days
Before I move on to the conquest of Europe,
allow me to take
a look at the effects of the plague on an
individual.
Yersinia Pestis initially likes to infect
rats and other rodents.
It takes from ten to fourteen days for plague
bacteria to exterminate a contaminated rat
colony.
For the following three days, the fleas infesting
these rats will lay in wait, fasting, until
new prey walks nearby.
This prey can be another rat, but a hungry
flea will not think twice before attacking
a human.
After an infected flea bites a human host,
Yersinia Pestis will invade his or her bloodstream.
One of the first symptoms of contagion is
the swelling of a lymph node, most often in
the groin, thigh, armpit, or neck.
The lymph node will grow in size, taking the
appearance of a swollen, blackened and painful
bubo.
Which gives its name to the bubonic plague.
For three days, the infected individual may
feel fine, while the disease incubates.
Then, early symptoms will appear, growing
in severity very quickly: fever, headache,
chills, widespread weakness.
After that, it’s only a matter of a three
more days.
Then, in more than 80% of cases, the infected
individual will die.
It takes 14 days for Yersinia to exterminate
a rat colony.
Another three days before infected fleas contaminate
the first human.
Six days later, the first human dies.
That makes a 23-day period from the introduction
of plague amongst rats to the first human
death in a given community.
A strange number, 23.
Try and divide 2 by 3 and what do you get?
Zero point 666.
[Caption on screen: 0.666….]
And whose number is 666?
Of course, I am sure there is no relation,
I am just teasing …
But the speed and perversion with which the
Black Death killed, well, it did have a demonic
quality.
In some cases, plague bacteria became concentrated
in the lungs and caused symptoms similar to
pneumonia.
This was pneumonic plague, and its course
was even more violent than the bubonic version.
People ill with pneumonic plague could die
as early as after two hours of catching the
disease.
What’s worse, pneumonic plague sufferers
can easily infect healthy individuals, as
they are beset with violent, bloody fits of
coughing.
The droplets they expel can easily infiltrate
other people’s airways, resuming the cycle
of contagion.
Surprisingly, however, the vast majority of
Black Death victims were not caused by human-on-human
contagion.
Infections were almost exclusively due to
bites from fleas that had previously sucked
blood off a rat.
The tiny parasites could attack directly after
feasting on rat’s blood, or sometimes they
travelled unnoticed aboard another animal
or human host.
The Black Death had to rely heavily on rats
for its invasion plans, and this had an effect
on both the geographic spread of the invasion
as well as its timeline.
Rats thrived on ships, especially merchant
ships, which at that time were able to travel
40 kilometers, or 25 miles, every day.
This is why the Black Death in Europe appeared
to conquer in leaps and bounds, rather than
following a linear path as it was in Asia.
Rat fleas are parasites that are most active
in the warmer seasons, which explains why
the springs and summers of the mid-14th Century
became unusually lethal.
‘Winter is coming’ … must have sounded
like a promise back then, as the plague lost
most of its contagion power in colder months.
Doctors at that time could do little to fight
the Black Death.
The most common form of treatment was ‘lancing’,
or piercing, the buboes, which expelled a
reeking black liquid.
Other methods involved leeching or bleeding
the ill, or washing their bodies with vinegar.
A much later book, Edward IV's Plague Medicines
of 1480, reports a medicine commonly used:
"Take an egg that is newly laid, and make
a hole in either end, and blow out all that
is within.
And lay it to the fire and let it roast till
it may be ground to powder, but do not burn
it.
Then take a quantity of good treacle, and
mix it with chives and good ale.
And then make the sick drink it for three
evenings and three mornings."
Certainly futile, but at least the ale was
good.
Europe shall fall
In 1344, the Golden Horde decided to lay siege
to the port city of Kaffa, on the Crimean
peninsula.
Since the late 1200s, Kaffa had been under
the rule of Genoa, one of the Four Italian
Sea Republics.
The Genoese resisted the Mongols for three
years, but in 1347, reinforcements from the
Golden Horde arrived, and they brought with
them something undesired: the plague.
An Italian lawyer, Gabriele De Mussis, described
the last stages of the siege:
"The whole army was affected by a disease
which overran the Mongols and killed thousands
upon thousands every day.
The Mongol leader ordered corpses to be placed
in catapults and lobbed into the city in hopes
that the intolerable stench would kill everyone
inside."
Catapulting your own dead soldiers inside
the city walls… that’s a tactic that would
certainly please General Black Death.
But Gabriele’s is the only account of such
an event, so it may have been an exaggeration.
Nonetheless, the infection soon spread within
the city walls.
And from there, pushed out by the double threat
of the Mongols and the plague, the Genoese
merchants escaped by ship.
The war waged by the Black Death in Asia had
been on land, relying on caravans and the
fast Mongol cavalry.
The invasion of Europe would be a more nautical
one.
In October of 1347 one of the Genoese ships
landed in the Sicilian port of Messina.
It was clear to the port officials that something
was wrong: most of the crew were dead, and
the rest spoke about a mysterious disease
that had ravaged them.
The survivors were prevented from leaving
the ships and, after a few days they were
all dead.
A contemporary account reads:
“The sailors brought in their bones a disease
so violent that whoever spoke a word to them
was infected and could in no way save himself
from death...
There then appeared, on a thigh or an arm,
a pustule like a lentil.
From this the infection penetrated the body
and violent bloody vomiting began.
It lasted for a period of three days and there
was no way of preventing its ending in death.”
So, ‘whoever spoke a word’ to the sick
was infected.
No one had thought about the rats.
Loyal to their black Master, they had scurried
over the ropes connecting the ship to the
docks.
These tightrope walkers were the executioners
of Europe.
The outbreak at Messina is often cited as
the first landing of the Black Death in Europe.
But the Genoese sailors from Kaffa made several
other stops, both before and after Messina,
every time spreading the plague in so-called
‘metastatic leaps.’
Black Death had arrived in Constantinople
in May 1347, where it had launched from the
Adriatic coast.
It reached Marseilles in September.
Throughout Autumn, the Genoese, or those who
had been infected by them, landed in all major
trading hubs of the Mediterranean: Dubrovnik,
Venice, Pisa, Genoa, Valencia.
All these ports were the bridgeheads for the
invasion force, which then broke through to
the mainland.
More merchant ships fell to the Black Death,
resulting in more metastatic leaps.
By March 1348, Southern France, Northern Spain
and almost all of Italy were living under
the shadow of the Conqueror.
The wealthy city-state of Florence had been
struck harder than other Italian towns.
It is estimated that 70% of its citizens died
within the few early months of the plague.
The outbreak inspired seminal author Boccaccio
to write his ‘Decameron’.
This is how he describes the massacre:
“It first betrayed itself by the emergence
of certain tumours in the groin or the armpits,
some of which grew as large as a common apple,
others as an egg...
Many died daily or nightly in the public streets.
Of many others, who died at home, the departure
was hardly observed by their neighbors, until
the stench of the bodies carried the news.”
The Black Death then crept northward.
From the French Mediterranean bridgeheads,
the hordes of Yersinia-infected rats moved
inland and reached the Atlantic ports.
It was a ship from Bordeaux that took the
plague to England: the first town to be infected
was Melcombe Regis, where the epidemic broke
out shortly before June 24th.
London fell in August 1348.
By January 1349, the population was so depleted,
especially of clergymen, that the Bishop of
Bath wrote this to his diocese:
“The plague... has left many parish churches...
without parson or priest to care for their
parishioners...
Therefore, if parishioners are on the point
of death and cannot secure the services of
a priest, then they should make confession
to each other... if no man is present, then
even to a woman.”
The whole Kingdom had been contaminated by
the end of 1349.
Further North, Norway was the first Scandinavian
country to be invaded.
Oslo fell first, in the autumn of 1348.
The outbreak in Oslo was mercifully stopped
by the advent of winter weather, but it broke
out again in the early spring.
The following year, the Black Death completed
its pincer movement against Norway, with a
second landing: the Ghost Ship at Bergen,
plague’s own Naglfar, was a ship of wool
merchants from the English port of King’s
Lynn.
Taking Oslo was a strategic masterstroke for
the Black Death.
The city was a major trading hub for the Hanseatic
fleet, a League of rich and powerful merchant
towns stretching from the North Sea to the
Baltic.
Needless to say, their merchants sailing off
Oslo disseminated a cargo they could not fathom
to new destinations – Denmark, Sweden, and
Northern Germany soon fell.
The new front opened in the spring of 1350
and moved southward, crushing the populace
with the same plague invasion that had entered
Southern Germany from Austria.
Now that Black Death had spread to almost
all of Europe, it plotted its next move.
This was one that would spell disaster for
many conquerors in later centuries: invading
Russia.
It had already tried, entering from the East,
but the Golden Horde had stopped the caravans
along the Silk Road.
Now, nobody would stop the scourge of Nations.
The plague entered the principality of Novgorod
in the late autumn of 1351, but the onset
of the cold stopped the outbreak.
But is was only temporarily: the progress
of the disease resumed in the spring of 1352,
reaching Moscow the following year.
The Black Death reached the border with the
Golden Horde, this time from the west, bringing
its Odyssey full circle.
In the same year, the pandemic petered out.
Iceland and Finland were the only countries
that had evaded the Apocalypse; the rest of
the continent was on its knees.
After the End
The death toll is still debated.
According to conservative estimates, the Black
Death had swept away 20 to 30 percent of Europe’s
population.
Recent calculations place the number much
higher, near 60 percent.
That’s 50 million men, women, and children
who lost their lives because of the bite of
the tiniest and humblest parasite one could
imagine.
Humanity simply did not have the tools to
combat this invisible foe.
Doctors did not have a cure, and even preventative
measures were insufficient.
Germ theory was still centuries away, but
authorities did understand that the proximity
of contaminated individuals would spread the
disease.
Several cities implemented quarantines, preventing
travelers from entering within their walls.
What they could never realistically hope to
contain was rats and fleas, creeping in from
everywhere undetected.
What did stop the Black Death, then?
It was a combination of two elements.
First, the onset of longer, colder winters
that killed off plague-carrying fleas.
Second, the disease itself was too effective
to be efficient.
The plague killed off its victims too quickly,
rats and humans alike.
This prevented them from travelling further
afield, carrying the bacteria to more and
more hosts.
The Europe that slowly recovered after the
year 1353 was a transformed continent.
Surprisingly, some of the societal changes
were for the better.
The poorer sections of the population enjoyed
a better diet, better working conditions and
a longer life expectancy.
This was a consequence of the reduction in
workforce: it prompted feudal lords to increase
their labourers’ wages and to find innovative
ways to increase the productivity of their
lands.
The epidemic also had an impact on the spread
of culture and education.
As travel to traditional University cities
became dangerous, new scholarship centres
were founded, allowing for the multiplication
and diversification of academia.
The Black Death may have eventually died out,
but its carriers, the Yersinia Pestis bacteria,
evolved into a different strain.
A strain more selective , yet equally malicious:
one that would be able to pick its victims
based on their age.
This became the second wave in 1361, one that
would target specifically the younger rungs
of society, the most innocent and vulnerable:
this would become known as ‘The Second Pestilence’,
or ‘The Plague
of Children’.
But
this is a story for another day.